all right in this man welcome bro you
already know king of battle rap the king
of battle rap what makes you get
freestyles what makes you the king of
Battle Rapper I've been doing it before
battle League was Battle leagues that's
why I'm a king of battle rap before they
start uh made it a corporate thing and
bring it into the building and kind of
monetized it I was I was Battle rapping
that's how I mean what is it about
Philly man that the battle rap [__] is
just so like
you know I feel like you guys are just
like a walking Smack DVD out there yeah
man it's real the coach is real heavy
out there it's um there's a commonwealth
City so it's like State and it's just
like real competitive and we all bunched
in together it's like real houses it
stores people on top of people so the
competitiveness is real heavy so when it
comes to battle rap it's real aggressive
and sometimes it can spill out into
Street and [__] when did you feel like
the battle rap [__] cause like you're I
feel like you're really in your bag
right now when it comes to like being
looked at as like one of the elite guys
in that world like when do you feel like
you kind of had hit your stride in terms
of getting your respect in that world
because it's like a very
it's it's like almost like a
I feel like you could be a die-hard
hip-hop head and not know what the
[__] going on in the battle rap world
because they are so different and it is
like such a sub-genre of it's almost
like we have to be baptized in the
battle rap culture now you have to go
through something you have to have the
near-death experience or come close to
dying from them to even sanctify you as
being anybody that has any validity of
saying anything or speaking about battle
rap coach it's that intense right so
that's why I don't speak on it yeah so
with that being said
um it's a high regard for battle rappers
and their accountability so over the
weekend it was a battle rap it was a
battle big battle League you were here I
was here for that so it was the
ownership battle League which in the
main event being a king Bob versus
Daylight they like being a residential
West Coast so yeah that's a beast so
shot them they like and we are from the
same battle rap click which is dot me
T-rex murder moot uh daylight Jesus big
cannon real deal so that's a serious
screw yeah you guys are like the NWO
yeah and I got a lot of flack from that
from being from Philly and being that as
a New York based click but the
Daylight's from LA right so it's all
over there yeah is there other clicks
like that yeah you got gun titles you
got uh uh The Goonies which is ahead
about twerk uh you got gun titles which
was kind of like coke coke co-founded by
uh Tay Rock and super surface
research yeah so yeah you got a little
like clicks Dark Side you got a bridge
Rothstein and T-top so it's like little
sub clicks and yo what's the name of our
guy rum knitties from Phoenix right he's
from he's from Phoenix XZ he's down with
a a
[__] my badge you got it get you Gotti
and him are called uh uh every [__]
bar efb I like that see all this [__]
like I know the names but bro I'm not in
tune with the battle [__] like that I
just feel like I don't have the
bandwidth to like learn this like when I
was a kid I used to download the battles
on Napster yeah like when it was like
Supernatural and Juice yeah those those
guys is like almost like ancient
artifacts compared to where it's at now
it's so special and then I would no
disrespect to those guys no but you guys
are the [__] goats they are the
[__] gods of this [__] with the
freestyling off the top of the dome
right right [__] in the room and all
that you're in the crowd it's different
it's no it's different now it's brand
[__] got wavy hair dreadlocks
baldies there's [__] members there's
blood members yeah it's intense it's
Latin King well no and then like there
was like The Smack DVD era and like I
got my name because I used to sell a
bunch of bootleg mixtapes and and DVDs
and [__] at the swap meet so I was like
The Smack DVD errors are probably the
the highest like peak of me being like
super engaged in that [__] and then
obviously I know who's killing it like I
know yourself I know Murder mooc sues my
boy's incredible uh yeah there's there's
guys that especially Loaded Lux you know
all these guys of course there are
legends that if you're a part of the
culture you have to know who they are
I'm just not I I haven't bro I've
watched a few like in the last year but
like
when there's these big events I feel
like I'll just catch the highlights on
Twitter right right so battle rap is
like a um it's like a revolving door so
you're only good is your last battle and
if you don't do very well they put you
in a box so I mean if you don't do other
things to uh to to come to to pose that
so I went and built the whole leverage
on the other side of the spectrum with
my music right reintroducing myself as
an artist or reading and creating myself
always into the plant and putting out a
new project where I got the battle rap
culture and I got take rock on there I
mean I met that man I got Benny The
Butcher I got a a a a a vato Corey Guns
Beanie Siegel freeway right I got all
the like the top spitters on my drone so
I use that the leverage and the buzz
that I built with my freestyles on
social media and the content and uh and
and the projects and the material that I
was putting out outside of battle rap to
leverage battle rap to get the bigger
bags and the bigger looks because once
you lose in the eyes of the culture they
put you in a certain box and it's like
boxing so you got to climb back up the
ranks until get to the top brass and
compete with like the top tier guys if
you got the catalog you got the music
outside of it it's almost like
it would it would behoove them to not
include you and [__] because you got a
fan base you you running it up on your
own you know what I'm saying for sure
and Shout out I mean a lot there is
there is a a stereotype and I don't know
how true it is or not but back in the
day there used to be a lot of the guys
who did battle rap weren't great at
making records I mean that's the number
one stigma and I I was the guy who
bridged that Gap right I was one of the
first guys who started out battle
rapping on the corners of Philadelphia
and then in front of the Chinese stores
and stuff like that and actually took it
corporate and made an album and came out
with a full-fledged album and yeah I
mean was able to you know go like walk
on Take a Walk on both sides right and
still having a seed planted in battle
rap coach as well as like mainstream I
mean releases and stuff like that
because at 2008 when I battled my son
the world series of hip-hop I was still
currently signing bad boy and was like
currently like like back then a
recording for my for my solar release my
son shantama yeah so yeah so like that's
how before I go back and that was before
smack was created at that event smack
was the actual cameraman he was hired to
do a service so now look at them now to
where their full-fledged company and got
the caffeine deal and all the things
they got going on so I was a part of
that I'm a part of those building blocks
and I just don't get my credit but I
embraced that fact so that's why I'm
here still 20 years later beating these
young opponents up beating a new
competition up getting there with the
youngins let them know that I got that's
considered some would say pastor's
promise still got enough in the tank to
get in there and destroy These Guys
these young guys